[موسيقى]
معلومات جيدة عن ساحة المطار
والنموذج الأولي جاهز للغد
[موسيقى]
حسنًا ، ها نحن اليوم هو اليوم المهم وهو
اليوم الأول من عرض الخريجين العالمي
لنكون ممتعًا حقًا لكثير من الأشخاص الذين
يأتون لزيارة المعرض  وربما
لم أذهب أبدًا إلى معرض للتصميم من
قبل ، وأعتقد أنه من المهم
مساعدة الناس على فهم تأثير
هذا التصميم في حياتهم اليومية ،
فنحن نواجه بعض
التحديات الهائلة التي أود أن أقولها ، ومن
المشجع جدًا أن أراك تعرف هذا تمامًا
عقول شابة لامعة تتعامل مع هذه
التحديات بشكل مباشر ولا تبتعد
عن أي شيء ، لذلك أردنا أن ننظر إلى
ما يمكن أن يكون مشكلة ملحة في عام 2050
والمشكلة التي حددناها هي
الزيادة المتزايدة للبكتيريا المقاومة للمضادات الحيوية التي
يعرفها الآخرون باسم البكتيريا
الخارقة لذا ننظر  في النماذج الأولية
هنا ونعتقد أن هذه هي
الحالة الخاملة للروبوت ، لذا فهو يتحرك
داخل مجرى الدم ليكون قادرًا على
اكتشاف التغيير في التحفيز كما هو
تقترب من البكتيريا التي تسبب
عدوى داخل الجسم
وبذلك تكون قادرة على تغيير
شكلها بحيث تنتقل من
وضع السكون الأولي هذا وفي
وجود البكتيريا القريبة من حولها
وتبتلعها بشكل أساسي أو بيرس إلى
جدار الخلية ، لذلك ذهب هذا المستشفى ،
فلنبدأ من النسيج ، فالنسيج
نفسه الآن في المستشفى عادة ما يكون عبارة عن
مزيج من القطن والبوليستر هذا مصنوع بالكامل من
الخيزران لأنه مضاد للجراثيم بشكل طبيعي ،
لقد تعرضت لحادث سيء للغاية
منذ ثلاث سنوات كنت أعاني من نزيف في المخ.
كنت خارج وحدة العناية
المركزة ، لم يكن الأطباء متفائلين
وقالوا لي أن عليك أن تقول
وداعًا لأصدقائك
وعائلتك وبعد أن تحسنت ، ولحسن الحظ ، أريد أن
أرى هذا المشروع لأرى إلى أي مدى
يمكنني دفع تصميم المستشفى إلى الأسفل
إذاً ، هنا مستشعر درجة الحرارة هنا
سيكون ضغط الدم والأكسجين
الذي يتم تحديثه على تطبيق كل 10 ثوانٍ
لإعطاء نظرة عامة كاملة عن
المريض طوال اليوم.  تلعب gn
دورًا كبيرًا في معالجة بعض
التحديات التي نواجهها اليوم
، وأعتقد أن التصميم الشاب هو مكان فريد
لتحديد تلك التحديات ومن ثم
تقديم حلول ذكية لها ،
وأعتقد أن التصميم يلعب دورًا بالغ الأهمية
لتغيير العالم.
هذا التصميم يراعي ما يحتاجه المستخدمون
وكيف يختبرون ويتفاعلون
مع المنتج وهذا أعتقد أن
أهم طريقة يساهم بها التصميم في
حل مشاكل العالم
كمصممين يمكننا مساعدة
البيئة وأيضًا أنواع أخرى من المشكلات لم
يفت الأوان أبدًا  لإحداث تأثير في
أذهان الناس لإحداث تغيير